[Music]
breaking it for multiple sources
reporting the Oakland days have made an
agreement on a new site the stadium will
now be built on part of the tropicana's
property thank you for joining us at 4
I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm David charnzen
for Brian the move comes after that
formal announcement just a couple of
weeks ago that the A's would be building
the stadium on land owned by Station
Casinos eight Sports now reporter Ron
Futrell here in the studio with the
details Ron this is sort of a little
change after that big announcement a
little bit moving a few blocks East is
what they're doing here David and
Kirsten what we got the Oakland
Athletics are throwing a little bit of a
curveball on their site location for a
new ballpark reports are they are moving
a little few blocks East on Tropicana in
fact the Tropicana Hotel Site one of the
sites they were looking at early on in
the process this would put the ballpark
right there on the Las Vegas Strip the
A's play here often for Big League
weekend their minor league team the
aviators play at Las Vegas ballpark now
the A's have an agreement to buy the
land where the old Wild Wild West Casino
was just west of I-15 on Tropicana but
the Nevada independent says they now
have a deal to buy the Tropicana site
the hotel would be demolished also the
deal would reduce the amount of special
tax District money needed from 500
million dollars to less than 400 million
Don Logan with the aviators recalled
recently the search the A's went on to
find property in Las Vegas
I was the chauffeur I took John and
Sandy and Dave Cavill and we drove
around the valley and kind of acclimated
him with what was going on and had some
meetings with elected officials and I
just started opening doors for him so it
said it you know like they've said you
know they've been very deliberate and
very thoughtful and in examining every
opportunity here
now the A's have this season and next
season still on their contract with
Oakland's Alameda Coliseum they're
looking at playing at the Las Vegas
ballpark Downtown Summerlin until a new
stadium is built they figure by 2027
here in Las Vegas attendance has been
way down in Oakland and the A's have the
worst record in Big League baseball
right now now the state legislature
still has to approve the special tax
District where those who use the
ballpark would pay the taxes it would
not be a general tax on Nevada and still
a lot to be done before the A's play
somewhere here in Las Vegas now the
Tropicana Hotel Site I'm Ron Futrell
eight news now